heads up guys my name is a Jonah welcome
back to my game engine series the first
of all no I have not forgotten about
this series and there's been plenty of
other content going on on this channel
and the reason for that is I'm just in a
bit of a video making mood I'm trying
new things I am just really enjoying
making all sorts of different videos so
nothing is going away
there's just probably gonna be a lot
more videos on this channel going
forward at least as long as this mood of
mine continues anyway what are we going
to do today so last time we basically
wrapped up the basics or the first kind
of vertical slice of our viewport
situation and else like seen pupils so
check out that video if you haven't
already because that's kind of laid into
what we're going to be doing today now I
mentioned at the end of last video
because usually what I do is before I
make this video I watched the last one
and see if I mentioned what we'd be
working on and I said that I didn't know
what we'd be working on which is a
little bit unfortunate because now I
really don't know what to do so what
we're going to do today I have decided
is we're basically going to take a look
at this whole I am gooey event situation
because we could just kind of shove that
under the rug and pretend that it's not
a thing for a while and then later come
back to it but that's I don't I don't
like that way of developing software I
think that if you have a problem you
should fix it and then go forward
there's something really satisfying
about having a like an application or a
game that you've made that might be
minimal and features but those features
are rock-solid you know and I'm saying
instead of having like you know
essentially what something that might
look like hazel dev but like half the
stuff just doesn't work what causes a
crash or just it just doesn't work very
well so it's it's nice to work on
something and try and get it like as
high quality as possible and that's what
I'm going to do here today even though a
lot of people might be excited for new
features I think this is probably a
better thing to do going forward so the
first thing we're going to do is I'm
going to switch over to dare screen and
we're gonna take a look at Forks so
there was a petition for me to use a
dark theme so I'm just going to do that
done see how much I care about you guys
so I mean I don't particularly mind
using the dark came for fork because
it's just it's for I don't use it that
much visual studio obviously I do like I
did prefer the dark theme but I'm not a
I'm not a light theme hater there were a
bunch of people in back
job that used light themes and guess
what I I talked to those people and I
had friendly conversations with them so
I don't hate light them so that if there
are any light themed people out there
drop a comment below I mean at your own
risk because I know that you'll get
attacked but not from me
I'll give you I'll give you a love heart
thing if if if that's the case the
reason I opened Fork is because I wanted
to take a look at some of the things
that have that have been done to hazel
so this was what we did last week and
then there are some there are some dips
that that got merged in I have been
really bad in general and actually
looking at github and seeing what has
happened and responding to pull requests
and all that stuff and I'm sorry for
that I know I should be a little bit
more into this version of hazel just
obviously if I'm developing hazel dev
I'm more involved in that and this is
kind of like I sit down in front of the
camera and I start working on hazel for
you guys as like the game engine series
and that's what that is
so because of that I've been a little
bit hesitant to do things off-camera as
much and I figured that I just start
this episode by looking at not maybe not
all the pull requests because I know
that people will get really sick of that
very quickly but maybe I'll have a pull
request episode once a month or
something like that where I look at
specifically a pull request but at least
we can look at the actual stuff that has
been merged into the inter hazel into
the repository so first of all there was
fixed wrong session name for shutdown
profile session so apparently I named
the shutdown thing startup which was
silly so obviously that's a good change
most of it is just fixing my mistakes
which is great there was apparently a
missing case here so in other words is
inside the shader well we actually have
the kind of switch statement with all of
the different branches here for the
based on what texture you're using and
just you know texture index for was just
not not implemented for some reason so
that's been added I I missed it must
have missed that from because we I
didn't I didn't add that specific code
but we did look at it last time adding a
bit of a virtual destruction on frame
buffer yeah so I must have missed that
somehow and I've still got the old card
so if we look at frame buffer
mm yeah see that's that's a that's an
amateur mistake so I put a whole bunch
of code inside OpenGL frame buffer into
the destructor of OpenGL frame buffer
which is very important such as deleting
the frame buffer deleting the textures
doing all of that stuff but since the
superclass or the base class which is
frame buffer does not have a virtual
disruptor if we treat that frame buffer
object as a frame buffer even though
technically you can't really have a
frame buffer instance because it's a
it's a pure virtual clock class or in
other words an abstract class you can't
really instantiate a frame buffer it has
to be one of the derived classes such as
OpenGL frame buffer so if you create a
frame buffer that is an opengl frame
buffer which is your only choice at this
point but then you use it as a frame
buffer and you delete the frame buffer
object as if it's a frame buffer pointer
which is what the shed point or the ref
would actually do then that destructors
not a run because it's gonna look at
this it's gonna say that it's got a
default destructor that's it that's all
you'll call right and the fact that the
child class is virtual doesn't mean
anything so in other words when we
actually created the frame buffer inside
at its layer which was here obviously
we're treating it as a frame buffer not
as an OpenGL frame buffer and that means
that when this frame buffer gets
destroyed it goes out of scope when a
turtle egg gets popped gets popped off
that opens a framer who would ever get
deleted in this scenario and not the
biggest deal because usually if the
editor layer gets destroyed it's because
the application has been closed so we
don't care about cleaning up memory
necessarily if the application closes
because it's gonna get reclaimed by the
operating system in fact it's a lot
faster in a lot of cases to just not
worry about even deleting memory on
application clothes but obviously going
forward very big mistake and where you
fix that is just by adding like a
virtual frame buffer destructor like at
this you can like set it equal to
defaults it doesn't matter as long as
it's like being overwritten we can
implement it like that whatever so
obviously we're not gonna add that code
in because someone else has done it so
let's take a look at this there's an
input destructor I want to revisit the
input class at some point because I hate
the way that I've done it and not sure
why I did it that way there should just
not be like an instance I used to do
this thing where I basically used like
kind of
Alton's and the reason I use singleton
specifically is just because for me at
the time that was just a clean way of
making sure that I can have a class that
is static and there's only a single
instance of it but I can still address
the members and have actual member
functions or methods inside that class
which again is not something that I do
anymore because I've just think it's
quite silly I just don't like it at all
so what I do instead usually as I make
the class fully static and then inside
the CPP file I just have basically a
static struct or something like that
which has all of them in all of the kind
of member data so that's I think what we
did for the 2d renderer where yeah so we
had as you can see here we have this is
like every function here is static we
have no Singleton's we have no members
no member functions or methods here and
we have no actual data here but if you
go to the CPP file we have this struct
called render a 2d data and then we have
a static instance of that inside this
translation unit which is a render to D
delt CVP and then that's kind of the
data that we address so it's effectively
a singleton but it's a lot cleaner and
it's none of the garbage that came with
having this and having like an
implementation for this it's also really
worth noting that in this specific in
this specific use case of abstraction
I'll say I know that sounds fancy what I
mean is like you know when we're dealing
with input right we what the reason we
have inputs set up this way is because
we want a derived version of that for
each platform so we want a Windows input
we want a Mac input you know Linux end
but we might want to and input a special
input for like Android or iOS or
anything else because input devices and
input platforms change right and
specifically I'm talking about platforms
here it's not the biggest deal in the
world because I think we're still going
through gel of W here but again if we
work on Android and we want to touch and
we want some of the things input becomes
a very complex topic however it's worth
noting that with with the example of
because we do the subtraction in in many
places we do it for the input we do it
for the window and we also do it for
what
we do it for we also do it for well all
of the rendering codes so if we look at
like a vertex buffer I just open the
buffer the H you know we have kind of
all of our apps all of our kind of
render API agnostic or independent like
buffer code here like index buffer and
vertex buffer and then we have an
implementation of that that's like Open
GL buffer now these look the same
between how we treat our rendering API
stuff and how we actually treat like
input stuff on Windows stuff but in
reality they're very different and I
don't think I want to treat them this
way going forward the reason is that
with a renderer API you don't know what
render api is gonna be used until you
actually launch the application it's not
a compile time decision right so I'm on
Windows technically speaking when hazel
supports more than just OpenGL I could
pick between DirectX OpenGL or Vulcan
that's totally fine right
I could just pick any of those and in
fact may be picking none of them as well
having like a kind of like a headless
situation here would also be ideal maybe
for testing other parts of the engines
engine that doesn't require you know
rendering anything to the screen that
way you could run it home like a Linux
server and you wouldn't really care
about there being a window that be
there'd be nothing there be no context
to render to and because of that I think
I even accounted for that because if you
look at some of this code you know we
have inside buffer dot CPP for example
you know we're creative we have around
our api none so that's why I run render
api non-existent is you could choose any
api and that is clearly a runtime
decision the reason it is the reason
that's the case is because you know it's
nice to be able to but also we're like
we've decided that we want to be able to
basically say that like hey on startup
make a decision as to what api you want
to use right and in that case you could
just based on certain factors you might
be like I'll use DirectX so I'll use
whatever and it'll be based on a
configuration file whereas if the binary
literally does not have the code for
Vulcan compiled inside it the hazal
binary I mean then there's nothing you
can do you literally need a different a
different binary file to be able to run
hazel with Vulcan or something like that
which is clearly not what we want we
want all the api's compiled in there if
they've kind of
you know if they're available in that
platform so for windows would be DirectX
Vulcan and OpenGL and if that's
available you can then make that
decision at runtime
now window and input is not like that
you know if we have windows in
fertilization then presumably in the
future Mac OS input or Linux importer
Android input or whatever there's no
there's no runtime decision here if
you're on Android you can't be like yeah
I want to use Windows input no that
doesn't exist right and so because of
that that clearly should be a
compile-time decision because of that is
totally okay in my opinion to just make
an input class that has a bunch of
static functions like it does here and
then the implementation for those static
functions are inside files such as
windows input dot cpp then in that case
you know you have the specific functions
to link to and those files only get
compiled on the respective platform
that's a much better way of doing
something like this instead of having
this ridiculous mess of get Mouse X and
then that directs to get Mouse X input
which is a virtual function and going
through all that I don't know exactly
why did it this way back in the day
maybe this was just like a new piece of
code that I like to experiment with
because that's another thing you should
know about me I like to just I'm not
afraid of just putting in some
experimental corridor stuff that I have
never done before because I just thought
of it on the spot or whatever into this
because for me this is all like an
evolution of you know software this is
me working on hazel this is not like a
you know a udemy course of like this is
how to write a game engine from start to
finish we're not we're never gonna go
back on our word no this is us writing
something together as we go right I have
hazel dev and that's partially written
but it's not you know it's not a
complete engine that I'm then just
copying and showing you guys how to do
that step-by-step in my opinion that
would be boring because there'd be no
discussion there'd be no you know let's
try this and then maybe we'll go to this
nor that it would just be very
one-dimensional and also I just I
decided to take you guys on this journey
with me rather than spending a year or
so writing a fairly complete game engine
and then making videos on it which would
just I don't know who put me a year out
of my life doing nothing basically
nothing of value I mean because I'd have
to invest a year of my time and then go
back and do this
anyway long story short I'll stop
rambling this what this episode is
turned into is a bit of a maintenance
episode so we're gonna fix some of these
things so I want to fix the input class
event class yep that's fair enough frame
buffer having a virtual destructor in
graphics context having a virtual
destructor and render our API having a
special destructor I also really want to
start implementing another end or API
soon we are probably I think I said that
I want to do metal for Mac OS soon and I
guess I still want to because Mac OS is
a platform I do want to support but
ultimately we will probably end up doing
either DirectX or Vulcan have a feeling
it'll be Vulcan because then at least we
could run it on on Linux as well and I
know that a lot of people like Linux
even though the majority of people use
Mac compared to Linux if you look at
like steam statistics or something like
that it's like 5 or 9 percent of people
use Mac OS and like 1 or 2 percent of
people use Linux and then the rest is
Windows so it's still like the
overwhelming majority of people who use
not windows use Mac OS which is why it
is a high priority for me to support
that even though you guys are probably
all developers and you would probably be
using Linux instead of Mac if you were
going down the UNIX route but that
doesn't matter because you know sorry
guys it's it's about it's about the
actual it's about the players it's about
what the people who are going to be
using hazel not to necessarily develop
in but to actually create games and you
know sorry I realized that means the
same thing it's for the people who are
going to be playing games what do they
want he's like what platform are they
gonna be using like playing a hazel game
on and the answer is gonna be Mac even
though at this stage obviously it's
still very much an in development engine
you guys would be surprised at how
quickly it can go from an engine that is
seemingly in development and completely
not capable of making a game to in a
week for example being like ok now we
can make again because this stuff cannot
change very quickly anyway so that's
that's that commit and then finally we
have just a follow-up of this lovely
Santa's just making sure that this
change goes into hazel
not as well because hazelnut and this
was in sandbox I think the missing
texture branch
all right so we'll kind of we'll update
to that so if I just check out master
which should go to that now I have local
changes here and I have a feeling that
they're they're rubbish so I'll just
discard them
and then we'll just check out master
core just done pull as well or fashion
and pull whatever okay when we should be
we should be on the latest commit
sometimes this is a lot of the times I
end up actually checking out the
particular commit but if you do that it
kind of it kind of disconnects you from
head and that's not the best thing to do
either okay so now we've now we're on
the latest code okay so first step is
I'm going to refactor this input class
to not be like this now hazel dev I
already do this for hazel dev and I'm
not really sure even how but if we look
at windows window dot CPP this is the
actual implementation of this again as I
mentioned this is not something our
sorry windows window I meant windows
input this is not something that is
going to you know Connor you're not
gonna want to have both windows input
and Linux input compiled in the same
binary ever because one is compiled on
Windows and for windows one is compiled
on Linux for Linux so what that means is
that we can come in and clean up some
this code so windows input or H is
deleted and also input your age there is
there is an input or CPP file which
basically just again does all this stuff
which is completely garbage let's delete
input on CBP so we've kind of cleaned
that up now right there's not gonna be
constructor there's not gonna be a
destructor there's not gonna be any of
this stuff everything's gonna be static
and I'm just going to take this and
massively clean it up so get a mouse
position get Mouse X&Y oops not constant
I don't know why sometimes I
automatically write comments like that
just a habit sir none of this create
stuff none of this protective stuff you
guys can see how much this classes has
like become so much more basic because
of the fact that we just don't need
anything else now
okay we have get mouse position mouse
button press this is like the mouse
button stuff is like the cable stuff
it's very sparse at the moment but
that's okay and if we go to Windows
input so Windows input is automatically
changing I'm just gonna using the you
guys can't see that but I'm just
renaming or doing a finer place of
Windows input to input we're going to
include hazel is it inside core hazel
core input dot H and this whole impulse
in as well I'm gonna replace with
nothing at all and then yeah so this
just kind of just get Mouse X get Mouse
Y situation just ends up returning this
which is fine I guess yeah I mean that's
kind of it you know that's really all
you need and you can see that you know
we have the static kind of declarations
of the functions here and then since
this windows input of CPP file gets
compiled on Windows the linker is gonna
link those those declarations to these
definitions and that's what we're gonna
get and that's it no indirection nothing
we just have normal functions everything
should still compile and run
and obviously that massively cleans up
our code so let's be nice and let's
commit that I mean I guess I should test
it first but I mean it's not really
worth it you're being tested pretty
simple I mean everything's worth you
being tested sorry if I'm teaching you
bad software engineering practices
alright so we're just going to commit
we're gonna stage this stuff and we're
gonna immediately say reflected input
situation and I'm just gonna commit and
push that immediately done okay that's
that's how how dedicated I am to just
making those changes okay so coming out
of this I guess what we're gonna do a
more or less code review here I'll hazel
because that's what this episode has
become we've drinkin some orange juice
because that's kind of weird that I'm in
I think that I think that we might even
continue on this code review to the next
episode
is we are kind of running out of time
but what I do want to do and I still
need to do a patreon livestream like
right after that what I'm gonna continue
work on hazel dev and it's already
getting late so so let's was going to do
yeah so what I want to do now is fix
this I'm GUI kind of input situation so
you guys know that at the moment I can
move I can move the cameras and WASD but
that also kind of like if I'm in a text
box and I'm editing stuff that also
moves the camera
I also am unable to scroll because I'm
going advanced I want to take a look at
that situation now full disclaimer I
have no idea what's going on at all this
is gonna be me debugging this live so
this might take a while I don't even
know where to start at this point so
first of all I know that I'm going must
we have an arm gooey layer and that must
be kind of blocking events and the way
that it blocks advance at the moment is
basically it says handled for the event
so since I'm GUI Leia is the topmost
event that receives input and the way
that you can look at that of or see that
is by going to application and seeing
that we have an overlay here called I'm
guilty and then the UM GUI layer and
then what happens is in the run code
when we do our layer stack on update or
specifically I'm interested in sure
maybe well the events is what I'm
interested in so if we look at events
which is on event you can see what
happens as we go or we do an our begin
which it's like a reverse iterator so we
start from the end of the layer stack
and then we go we go kind of I guess
backwards and if the event is handled we
break so we don't pass it down to like
events further down if we did not do
this right if we just did that for
example then obviously like that is
physically what stopping the events from
happening if I scroll my mouse now
everything works right so step one is to
understand what's actually going on it's
very important to be able to wrap your
head around why exactly something is not
happening if you don't fully understand
the problem it's very difficult to fix
it just in the dust in my screen so now
that we understand the problem let's
talk about how we fix it so first of all
when do we want I'm going to actually
have access to this stuff like when do
we want I'm good
be able to block events now the only
time I can really think of and this is
this is important because we need to
think about the future here we can't
just think about how hazel works now
because then we'll have to come up with
a different solution when we change it
but ultimately speaking at the moment we
have WASD moving this camera that's not
that's probably not how you want this to
work at all because this is more or less
something that you probably want in your
own time we're in an editor maybe if you
hold the right mouse button or the left
mouse button and then use WASD you would
then start capturing that input sending
it to the viewport to move the camera
but ultimately speaking you probably
want to use the mouse and maybe with the
Alt key or something like something like
that to click and drag this and WASD is
just like that's something that you use
inside the actual game and that behavior
is probably going to be scripted inside
the game now if you have a camera like
unreal or even Unity I think where if
you hold right mouse button then you can
kind of use the WASD Keys to get more of
like a first-person camera and the first
person camera controller rather than
like a I don't know like a Maya or
blender style camera like a 3d program
style camera with the with the you know
mouse to orbit and do all that stuff
then that's the different story
obviously but ultimately speaking my
point is if I've clicked on this
settings panel and I'm clearly in the
Settings panel WASD shouldn't even do
anything but the theory is that it it
won't it's never gonna do anything
anyway because just pressing WASD should
probably not move your camera inside
your editor you need some kind of extra
input to make that happen so because of
that that's probably not a problem that
is worth specifically fixing now what we
do need to think about though is with
this on event thing so it does I am
going on to capture the mouse and does
it want to capture the keyboard now this
code which again as I mentioned I didn't
add myself what that means is that we've
basically we have an IM GUI window
focused and navigation is enabled
so that's okay that's for the keyboard
and the mouse okay yeah okay sir
that's a problem because if the unclick
two mouse is hovering over and I'm going
window or a widget is active or the
mouse was clicked etc then it's not
gonna do that now this this works fine
for if we had floating windows like we
did in the past so otherwise back in the
day when we just had like floating
little windows like this and the
viewport was an actually an I'm GUI
window but it was just like actually
inside our application that is the way
that we want to handle it because
obviously if we're floating over this we
don't want to dispatch events we have to
like specifically be but in this case we
have to be in this window but ultimately
we don't want to dispatch events unless
we're specifically not in any I'm good
we're windows but now the problem is
that our game is an inchoate window and
so because of that we need a little bit
more control so realistically what we
should probably do is if we go to I
wonder if the first thing that comes to
mind is perhaps excluding the viewport
window from like the whole event
situation so in other words if if the
currently active or focused winter is
the viewport keep the events going
because there's no I'm GUI event that we
necessarily need for viewport that we
don't want to send into the game right
so I don't know if there's a way to kind
of get the currently focused window or
somehow I know I'm GUI I've honestly
never done that before hazel dev has a
completely different solution I'm just
trying to come up with something
original here
because I don't think the one in hazel
dev is the best but so is window focus
so we can see if the current window is
focused okay
there's also hover but I'm wondering if
there's a way to actually get the
currently focused window or
because like obviously we could just you
know is I don't focus now that's not
what I want the thing is like you know
we could obviously maintain this state
on our own and that's what we'll
probably do but I'm just I was just
curious to see if we can do that but I
guess I guess it's probably better to
that iron anyway so is window focused
okay what are the focus flags let's see
if there are anything useful so let's I
guess let's find enum of course you
Visual Studio Visual Studio please don't
unselect what I selected okay here we go
so any went none any child windows root
window any window root and child windows
I don't know we'll try no flags and
we'll see if that does what we want but
basically is window focus let's do a
little age set core one and then we'll
do work this so this is how I like to
just check that obviously the data that
I'm getting is actually correct and then
the other one I'm interested in hot is
actually positive so basically if we
begin a window and then we ask it is
it's all kind of contextual so if we ask
it is the window focused is the window
hovered then this should hopefully
basically give us exactly what we need
which is if this is true for the
specific viewport window keep sending
the events I don't worry because
obviously the I'm good thing that were
over or they were you know that is that
is active is is you know now focused is
true Harvard is false well I think when
I had this Harvard is it hover doesn't
work if the application is not focus
which just makes sense if we focus it
Harvard is obviously true if that's the
case and then focused if we do that okay
well there you go
so I guess what we probably want if you
want the WASD key to work then you
probably want people to be focused and
if you put is focus then send
through the other thing is with Harvard
I think you could probably safely ignore
Harvard the reason is that again if
you're inside here you like viewport is
in focus but if you drag your mouse over
the viewport suddenly as you can see
viewport is now hovered but you still
don't want to send the input in because
that would be wrong so long story short
we basically when we render the viewport
we need to set some kind of flag here
that says that hey you know if the
window is focused then don't don't block
events please like I need to get events
because the viewport is focused now how
we want to solve that specifically is a
bit of a different story to just solving
it I'm not sure what we could do
realistically is we could probably
disable the blocking of events if that's
focused and then re-enable it if it's
lost focus or something like that I'm
just thinking if that's the best way to
do it because we have an iron GUI layer
we could probably retrieve that from the
layer stack if we really wanted to and
then we could just set it directly on
the I'm GUI layer because it is a
specific layer that's blocking events is
not necessarily an ingrained engine
system so I guess what we'll do we'll
probably do that right so and it's it's
specifically a bit but but we want to
use that we want it this is something
that's important to do for a number of
things so in other words you know if
we've got something else out of focus
like if we've if this window is focused
then make sure you also don't or rather
if it's not focused make sure that you
don't do things like camera control
update because clearly it shouldn't be
necessarily update well camera
controller checks to see this input
state stuff so if we just don't off - at
the camera you know then it's not going
to yeah it's not gonna it's not gonna do
any of that stuff and it should be
completely fine for us to answer em
people focused
so this will be a bullying humble people
focus equals false we'll start it off at
false we can say that if the viewport is
focused will update the camera
controller will still do all of the
rendering stuff obviously if it's not
focused the we don't care about whether
on it's focused for that and finally so
now now let's test that out that should
stop that part so if we WASD and then if
we go here you can see WASD no longer
works we actually have to have the
viewport in focus which is cool and then
the next part is does application have
some kind of way of actually retrieving
an overlay or a snot doesn't doesn't
complain rubbish
we should probably rework this entire
layer stack a situation because again I
feel like I feel like I have some
different ideas the layer stack itself
does have an iterator and a reverse
iterator and Aleya I'm wondering if we
should just if we should just have an
I'm let's do that let's have let's have
a I'm gooey layer get I am gooey layer
function and don't want to be Const
probably not the reason is that we've
already got a pointer to it while I look
through the layer stack and I don't want
to spend more of today's time adding
assistant to that so to do is a complete
engine review and also rewriting the
layer stack if you guys want to see that
let me know and I'll probably do it a
bit sooner than I would otherwise but it
is still going to eventually happen so
now what we should be able to do is
inside I am go away oh we should have a
little ball here called
block I am going vents so events that
I'm Doris eaves do we block them or not
so we'll have this as I guess true or
maybe just block block events true and
then what we'll do is avoid set set
block events bull block block events
equals block just block events and then
basically what we'll do is if block
events will do will make sure that we
block these that's it I think right
because otherwise we're not going to do
anything so if I've done that correctly
I'm not even going to bother checking it
if I if the viewport is focused right so
we'll do if MV bought focused then we
can do application yet get I'm gooey
layer block events
you bought focus and I just realized
that we have to do that kind of
regardless so basically we'll get the
application and will tell the I'm gooey
layer to block events based on if the
people is focused on on so in other
words if the viewport is focused then we
don't want to block events so obviously
block events should be the other way
around so if the viewport is not focused
then block events from reaching the
viewport because if we don't do that
then well if we don't do that the events
are always gonna get through so we'll
we'll check this out and see exactly how
it works but basically if the viewport
is focused like it is now I should be
able to scroll the wheel because that's
really the only event I think we have
the moment but if I if I focus over here
I can't like I can still scroll so maybe
maybe scrolling and events should be
only active if the viewport is both
focused and hovered because you probably
want to I don't know if if this like
yeah so that's scrolling this is what I
mean you can say that this does both
right so realistically we actually want
to do
if you bought focused and viewport
Harbert equals I'm making another one
for this just to kind of make it just in
case we want to use it for other things
so now so we so block events so we
wanted to block events if the viewport
is not focused and not hovered is that
right no no no I guess so no what are we
trying to do here I hate this stuff so I
see this is this is another sign that
I've probably written this in not the
clearest way because right now I'm
having to really think about this to
figure out what I want so this is a
boolean that obviously will block event
so if block events is on then it's going
to set handle to something else right so
we want it to block advance if the
viewport is not focused so if it's lost
focus or if you're hovering over
something else so in other words if if
it's not Harvard if it's either out of
focus or not Harvard right so in other
words if it's if we're out of focus
but we don't want it to be on because if
it like if we're if we've lost focus but
we're hovering over it that's still not
acceptable we want to both be it should
be maybe should be allow events or
something like that because yeah that
that's kind of all over the place
but now if we kind of click on it to
focus and if we go off here so now you
can see I'm hovering over this if it
doesn't get it anymore and I also lose
okay so we focus and then if I go over
here you can see that I've still got the
viewport focused but the scroll wheel
here is working and not here so I need
to kind of have that going on and then
if we dock this and click back on
viewport I should be able to move it do
all my event stuff but then as soon as I
go off here there's scrolling is gonna
stop which is what you expect the key is
gonna continue because that's still
focused but then when I click here both
in my gone whoo ok that is the situation
so that's gonna be it
so I hope you guys enjoyed this episode
if you did please don't forget to hit
the like button and help
aboard this series and everything I do
by going to patron on confession Oh huge
thank you to everyone who does help
support this as I mentioned I'm gonna do
the hazel dev livestream so if you're
interested in catching me working for
like hours on the kind of 3d version of
hazel then definitely help support that
and you will get access to something
something like $5 a month for the
livestream access sir next time what are
we gonna work on I think we're I think
honestly I would probably prefer to do
some kind of engine review and fix up
the rest of everything else here the
layer stack can wait because it's not
like the most like it's not the most
it's not be I thought I feel like saying
this in Russian but I can't say it in
Russian I'm saying in English it's not
the most burning like thing at the
moment like it's not like we don't
really need to do that yet so I think if
all this I'm done will probably will
probably either do the code review next
time or orbit just get on with I guess
developing the 2d workflow and doing all
that stuff so let me know if you guys
want me to work on something specific in
the comment section below thank you for
watching and I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]